it's an honor to be here what do I do
I got it I got it okay so I'm going to
talk about economic models and for me a
model is going to be the same thing that
is really Andrew Gelman it's a
probability distribution over a sequence
so here's physics according to the great
physicist Richard Feynman think about
some this is fineman's metaphor think
about someone who does not know the
rules
but observes actions taken by two people
who are playing chess there's some of
the actions and from these limited
observations on the players moves the
observers job is to infer the rules of
the game of chess so Fineman saw that as
a metaphor for how physicists learn
about the laws of physics
so fineman's chess metaphor is close to
a literal description of what economic
scientists do it's going to be my theme
so but in economics sometimes the rules
of the game changed midstream Congress
is doing things this week and next week
that may change some of those so what we
want to do is we want to detect when
rules of the game have changed and how
and sometimes we even want to recommend
changes in the rules of the game so for
economics it's not enough for a central
bank it's not sufficient it's necessary
for a central bank to detect to detect
patterns using neural nets and random
for us because a central bank wants to
know what's going to happen under policy
interventions that change rules in
unprecedented ways unprecedent means
they're not in the data and because
experiments aren't possible here and you
don't want to live in a country where
there's an experiment being
usually I'll give you a come and see me
afterwards I'll tell you some country he
could go visit for their cities so
economics data a data analysis no matter
how sophisticated has to be tied into
Siri as the difference between Kepler
and Newton she reached us Steven
Weinberg's book explaining the world
about physics okay so I told you
economics has a tight definition of a
game it's due to John von Neumann so
here's his definition of a game it's a
list of players you know this definition
if you play soccer football it's a list
of players it's a list of legitimate
actions available to each player it's a
description of how rewards are payoffs
to each player depend on the actions of
all players that's a mouthful so what my
payoff depends on what all my teammates
do and what all my opponents Joe and
finally it's a description of who
chooses what when a timing protocol and
timing matters so what do economic
scientists do and I could change
economics to any kind of scientists so
four things first you observe colep some
observations and second thing you do is
do you detect patterns
sometimes that in fossil imposing
patterns the next thing is you build
theories to explain the patterns and
then the final thing you do is you
predict I'll come back and what you mean
why it might mean by predict so here's a
model so Andrew Gelman uses the same and
I Bayesian uses the same probability
distribution of our sequence of
observations hidden states indexed by
some parameters that's what I mean by
models could use a language stochastic
process so economic scientists you
observe you detect patterns so I'm gonna
say detecting patterns that's fitting a
non structural or non causal model and
it's got some parameters Delta we call
those those are non structural
parameters and we use Python and pandas
and scikit-learn to do that that's an
essential step you build theories and
you know both your pattern recognition
and your theories they're both models
but to have different different
parameters theta I'm gonna call those
our causal parameters and then the final
thing you do is you predict so what you
might predict is you might you might
predict assuming the patterns going to
stay the same so you might just have
estimated the parameters Delta or theta
that's what you want to model now you
have a machine for conditioning on data
and predicting into the future that's
under a given historical regime and it's
almost as if Fineman was saying that was
enough for him but economics often we
want to do it under alternative regimes
because we're going to change the rules
you know you know when your Deng
Xiaoping in China changed the rules and
made China look a lot less Venezuela and
a lot more like the United States so we
want to study what happens under
alternative regimes okay so I'm gonna
tell you what observations are they call
them wise and I'm gonna index them by
time and those are my observations and
why is that vector okay
pattern recognition so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna an on causal model I'm
gonna have a history of observations to
call it Y to the T I'm in a history of
observation that's just gonna be a
probability of tomorrow Y conditioned on
the history up to time T and some
parameters I'm gonna call that a
non-causal mal and lots of things that
you know about could be a it's basically
a nonlinear function and then a is gonna
be
that's a the model is gonna yield me an
innovation or shock process it's gonna
it's going to have a notion of news or
information that's what is notice that's
just the difference between why and what
I could predict basis on past data
that's that's the information and then
economists do some of the last thing is
they form impulse response functions
they ask me if I feed a sequence of
shocks in how are the dynamics of the
Y's gonna look like Engineers do that -
that's pattern recognition and okay
prediction I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
iterate the transition law and get
conditional distributions of the future
and they're not going to be point
estimates they're not going to say if
you pass the Trump tax bill GNP is gonna
grow at 4% it's gonna be probability
distributions characterize the
uncertainty and that's what physicists
wanted to
to characterize what we know and what we
don't know and they don't know a lot of
things and we know even less and we
should be honest about that so so
pattern recognition so this is hard for
macroeconomics because it's difficult
because if economy is growing we lose
two of our favorite naturally we lose to
our favorite machines for learning and
law of large numbers and the central
limit theorem because it's growing
because there's it's non-stationarity so
we have to do something to induce
stationarity so we can activate one of
those laws so we have controversial ways
of doing that it's also true as some
laws of economics change over time I
mentioned dang shopping we have to be
able to detect and recognize in our
pattern recognition when they may have
changed and then we need theory to
extract the stationary components and
make inferences about them so my friend
Lars Hanson at Chicago is a big leader
in that ok so now I'm going to tell you
about theory I'm done talking about
pattern recognition because I shouldn't
be talking about pattern recognition
here I should be learning and actually I
well I go to the gym every day i watch
youtube videos often of pi data
conference and i and i am a i'm thrilled
to be here because many of the stars of
those youtube videos are on this program
okay so now I'm gonna tell you about
theory so I'm gonna tell you about
abstract version of economic theory and
I'm gonna make this simple because I
want to keep the vector short but you
can lengthen the vectors by changing to
2n okay so I'm gonna have a state and I
have some controls so the state's a
state is what Laplace man it's a
complete description of the current
position of the system so my state is
going to be has some X ones those are
the states for player 1 X 2
those are states for player 2 and X n
those are states that for nature so
nature's gonna do some stuff like
weather stuff like well maybe we affect
weather so I'm gonna think of those that
may have been politically incorrect but
but anyway so so so X is a vector it's a
state and there's some things that are
controlled partly by the two players u1
and u2 so there's two players in this
game you can lengthen at the end so then
there's gonna be some shocks hitting a
system and those those are those are
shocks actually hitting the physical
system shocks to all sorts of stuff you
know some come from weather some come
from events abroad and I'm gonna I'm
gonna let them be a iid my shots are
gonna yard ID and then I then that's
content of the theory there's gonna be a
law of motion I chose to use difference
equations we often use differential
equations so the state next period is a
function of a state this period the
whole state the whole vector of controls
Silhouette what you do and what I do and
everybody else does and they use the
shocks that are pinching on the system
and their condition on the Thetas the
Thetas are the vectors of framers and
then the second thing is to you tease
they're gonna they're going to end up
somehow
they're going to be UTSA decisions of
the players are going to be functions of
the state that's a feedback law what
else could they be and they're going to
depend on the parameters so my
parameters theta are going to influence
that law of motion and they're going to
ultimately influence the G's so this is
only a piece of a theory because I have
to the natural thing is ask fineman's
question well I have imperfect
observations on the X's in the use but
how are the Jews being determined how
can I explain the G's those are the
decision rules so I want a theory of
what players are doing okay so here's
what I'm gonna do it I'm gonna say
players do what they want that's
economics players do what they want so
what do they want so I'm gonna tell you
I'm gonna I'm gonna endow them with some
preferences so remember von neumann said
i got to tell you
payoffs what players are trying to
maximize so I'm gonna I'm gonna this is
a dynamic thing I'm gonna endow each
player with a with a dynamic program
discounted dynamic program so each
player is gonna have a a function r1 or
r2 that summarizes how their payoffs are
at time T depend on the state and the
control you think of what else could
they depend on you know just situation I
have and what I do so there's two of
those or if there's a whole bunch of
players there's another there's all
these players and those are their
objectives
and I've restricted that just like a
control engineer would do it's taken
from control engineering the conditional
expectation of that discounted some of
those payoffs that's what the guys wants
to do and what he wants to choose as a
decision rule you as a function of the
state that's going to make that as big
as possible that's how he wants to do
and so the outcome of the theory is
going to be a set of decision rules that
solve that max problem so if you're an
engineer and mathematician you'll see
you'll say this is not a well posed
problem I haven't told you enough about
this to write a Python program
I've told you pieces of it so you know
Connie economics I like to do is if you
can't write a Python program you're a
bullshitter okay so now so I'm not done
okay so and now okay so now a theory and
observations so the measurements weird
we don't know we don't always get to see
the whole state this is Fineman again we
don't always get to see the whole
controls what we do is we are wise are a
function there's some perhaps non-linear
noisy function of the states and the
decisions
Fox News came into my head right now or
you know we get noising up we get some
information we get or anything New York
Times The Wall Street Journal you get
noisy signals on what's actually going
on and aid us are going to be some more
shocks okay
so now I'm going to tell you about
causal models there's two problems and
this is straight out of I learned this
at a cough is expand engineering
chemistry Congress to my two problems of
causal models there's a direct problem
and there's the inverse problem the
direct problem is you give me theta and
AM the measurements and I'm going to
simulate the observations you give me a
model I can generate observations you
give me all that stuff the inverse
problem is you give me the observations
and I want to infer a bunch of stuff I
want to further the structural
parameters I want to infer the hidden
states and I want to hit I want to infer
the hidden control variables perhaps I
want to infer all that stuff back all
that stuff out and this is a very
Bayesian or stand view I'm taking a
symmetric view about I'm forced to
that's the inverse problem okay so an
equivalent state there's an equivalent
statement of the inverse problem given a
good fitting non causal model I want to
infer those things okay so now I have to
complete I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm going
to complete the description of the game
and even with what I've said now there's
multiple games that I can write down
with that environment because I haven't
told you about timing protocols and and
what the different players are doing
assuming about what the other players
are doing so we're in a game my decision
rule ought to depend on what your does
my best decision rule depends on what
your decision rule is think about any
game you play your decision rule one
thing that's vital to you is a law of
motion of the whole system and what the
opponents are
their strategies so my strategy depends
on your strategy so you were gonna be
thrust into a fixed point okay so here's
the so I'm gonna tell you something
called Markoff perfect
this is closely this is an extension of
an idea of John Nash so player I I'm
gonna choose
I'm gonna choose a decision rule GI
that's mine to maximize what I care
about and subject to the following law
of motion I'm gonna I'm gonna say I know
the law of motion f I know how it
depends on my decisions you my moves and
your moves and now I'm going to assume I
know you - I means that's yours that's
your decision I'm gonna assume when I
make my choose my decision rule I take
your decision rule is given and now it's
a complete problem it's now a complete
dynamic programming problem it's no
longer [ __ ]
it's a complete problem you can you can
write a Python program you write that
program Python program and what you find
is strategic interdependence you find
that my GI G - I means and it's the
other guys or if there's a whole bunch
of players it means everybody else's my
decision rule depends on what everybody
else's decision rule is and they have a
symmetric equation and a Nash
equilibrium or as Markov perfect
equilibrium is a fixed point of that
that's a confess one game and now it's a
tight model and now we could think of
this as a model of an industry where
there's a bunch of producers
Python and Julia stuff like that
competitors I'll give you another
another another game this is called
stackelberg so I'm gonna change I'm
gonna change the timing and this is
going to change the outcome so in a way
I'm changing the rules of the game and
what's going to happen is the is the
final theories going to change so here's
the deal
player 1 chooses first G 1 first not
simultaneously see that fixed point is
those guys are essentially 2 zhing
simultaneously it settles down to I
different player 1 chooses first goes
first and then player 2 chooses G 2
knowing G 1 so G 2 is a the decision
rules a function of G 1 but now player 1
knows what that function is so player 1
can manipulate player two's decision
rules because he has that first mover
advantage that's it so the timing and
that leads to different outcomes so it
leads to you know it's a different game
looks very similar but but just by
changing the timing protocol I change
the outcome
now here's another game Monopoly there's
these two players I I have a single
player choose both of them so this could
be a model of a family guess what
there's a husband and wife what do they
do so this is this is one we're not to
get personal this is a model where
Carolyn chooses what both Carolyn and
Tom do
that's a monopoly that's different
outcomes and actually in some sense it's
a better outcome okay
so there's other games there's perfect
competition there's a Pareto planner
there's all sorts of things even with
this setup so one thing so now I'm
thinking about Fineman again so our job
is to figure out from the data which
game is being used so now notice what
I've done
change those games I changed the model
name of model is a likely to function
you know with enough structure I give
that to Andrew Gelman and Stan and his
team and pray your son comes out okay so
so the so alternative games define
alternative causal models and then we
want to compare models
that's what economists are supposed to
be doing that's what the that's what the
Federal Trade Commission or antitrust is
trying to do they're really you know
there's first-class economists trying to
do that is how can you tell whether it's
really a collusion in industry it's hard
to do okay so why do we want causal
models and now this could be a talk in
any anything so so you recognize this
dimension reduction the theory asserts
that the parameters Delta of the non
causal model are actually functions of
the parameters of the causal model theta
and theta might be a lot smaller
dimension than Delta so anytime you can
reduce the dimension of parameters do it
okay the other is interpreting the
shocks the shocks in the non causal
model are functions of the shocks in the
causal model can't interpret them unless
you have the causal model and then
finally thing is policy evaluation when
we're done with this we want to we want
to ask what's the optimal game we want
to we want to devise optimal policy and
that's going to lay an optimum problem
on a
tell me that tell me the best game to
play okay so so this is beyond Fineman
economics so we want to study
experiments that may amount to changing
the rules of the game so I said that
so models so okay okay so finally I'll
just say I've imposed this is some
people say this is right-wing economics
because it says people kind of know what
they're doing and they're acting in
their own best interests I don't
I think it's left-wing you can ask so
one thing is I've imposed in that spirit
I didn't post communism of models so
what do I mean by that the agents inside
the model have a prediction problem just
like the analyst does they're trying to
predict where the system is going and
embedded in their dynamic programming
problem is a prediction problem and no
how are they predicting they're using a
stochastic process in prediction theory
and they're using the same model that
the analyst is building it's a big fixed
point so if you ask do people disagree
about probability distributions no okay
so that's an incredible assumption but
it's scientifically it's it's a
dimension reduction assumption because
if I give everybody in this room a
different model
I've proliferated parameters and I've
gone into I've gone dimension expansion
you can't estimate it okay so that's
called rational expectations okay so
then okay oh yeah here's the deal
the CEO of quantity cons Johnson ker see
we have many examples I'll just tell you
what we do in called econ
because we fall short of where we want
them to do we have a whole bunch of
problems of direct problems we have far
fewer solutions of inverse problems and
we're we're being either shrewd or lazy
we're waiting for Stan
to do some things okay now I'm supposed
to do this oh I do allow oh yeah oh yeah
what do I do
okay I just want to show honey I just so
we have these lectures so this is this
is kind of propaganda I don't know what
I'm not a do I do
all right this is great you're observing
real-time learning is that a linux
person okay in okay okay so so we have
this website which the turski is called
quantitative economics and this is this
is all a stunt this is a deal we
simultaneously teach this kind of
economics and Python and every time you
write economics we write Python every
time we do Python we do economics so
here's some elder linear quadratic
dynamic programming problems and we have
an overview and then we teach you what
that is and then we look a look at this
law of motion all this stuff and then we
do a classic model and then we show you
the Python code and then and then that's
it and then do I do
okay so now I want to go back to I just
I want to stop now and I want to show
you one thing how do I kill this
oh he's a Linux guy too and then I'll go
to see did you I have one last slide I
gotta show ya okay okay think we just
gonna okay so I just go all the way down
okay
so just gonna conclude with fun so am i
saying anything new or was Fineman
saying anything no and I'm just gonna go
back ancient Chinese proverb this is
from 2500 years ago this is a message
huh the government has a strategy that
people have a counter strategy that's it
[Applause]
okay we have a few minutes for any
questions Tom are you okay to take a few
questions if no that's okay I think
we're we've got yeah we have about a few
minutes is there does anyone have any
questions comments
okay I think we're okay so that's a
really nice song Taylor my daughter so
in in my daughter was in fourth grade
I'm on TV at the nightly news talking
about unemployment they come and
interview me and I in my office and
after that after the so I do what I
think is a good job the phone rings as
soon as since my daughter and at fourth
grade and she says hey dad I just saw
you talk after I saw your talk I don't
see if I don't feel so bad about to be -
I got on my talking class
okay any did you hear wicked yeah so so
we've had some success the truth is you
have to do about half as much of each
that's just the truth so one strategy
that works well is if if we can teach
some basic economics where we do some
where will you teach it with linear
algebra and stuff like that and then
show them that and then turn on the
Python it really ignites them and you
know it can change people's lives first
thing is they get jobs they get summer
jobs and where's so so lots of I hate to
say this
lots of so lots of schools economics
gets pressure to compete with basket
weaving so you get you enlarge your
class and lower the requirements so you
don't use as much math as they had in
high school and then guess what they
don't learn anything so but and they I
guess what they don't get summer jobs
but like we've taught a couple classes
where they where they do Python and they
all get summer jobs and they so you can
change a few lives so I'm not gonna
mister we're all for changing lives okay
I think I think we're done we'll we'll
have our second keynote after lunch and
everyone enjoy your sessions
you